hi they reject nation I'm Greg Alva I'm
John Humphrey we just got back from Dan
and Alyssa's wedding go follow them on
YouTube it would be their wedding gift
from you guys region echinacea I did
from us Wow seven hours on the road
immediately hop it into this because
apparently e3 is going on right now 727
- everyone's like Keanu Reeves is in
this so we're gonna watch the game watch
the official trailer
[Music]
we watched the whole like whole long
gameplay trailer last year that was
awesome awesome
Samara leave mommy give me you blown up
all over the news are you wrong I just
want the money
you got the chip go to the bathroom wash
up we gonna be with you in a bit
this game is gonna become iconic
we are going to the major leagues
Oh No homeboys been shot
[Music]
[Music]
for a transition shot
[Music]
take the ship tanks every corporal cop
in this city it's gonna be blasting down
these doors I'm doing you and your
psycho friend here we didn't need all
this tension damn it
like Rick Ross
[Music]
motivation
[Music]
wait
[Music]
josè the press-conference video cool
[ __ ] he showed up oh damn he's actually
in the flesh yeah
cyberpunk wick it does feel like you're
there hey he's having just a hell of a
year I had no idea is gonna be in this
game
cyberpunk 2077 all right ice per wattage
back the guys are proceeding project the
red approached me and asked me to be a
part of their new project cyberpunk 2077
they were going on and on about how they
create this fast open world with a
branching storyline how you'd be able to
customize your character to reengage
choices and it's not something I knew
before but I was excited by and I'm
always drawn a fascinating story where
body modification has become an
obsession playing as an outlaw and
enhanced mercenary working in the sleazy
underbelly of this city
[Laughter]
odd 80 or breath it's cats it's funny
body language you know
[Music]
[Music]
Oh 16 20 20 baby look out awesome it
wasn't until he showed up on stage where
it really hit me Keanu Reeves is the
perfect person to be in cyberpunk
especially you know like that's a strong
association with some sci-fi work like
Johnny Mann Manik
that's where everyone's mind goes we
have Keanu Reeves in sci-fi Johnny Mann
monic and a walk in the clouds a walk in
the clouds speed to cruise control
obviously his association with the
matrix yeah having that kind of awesome
crazy storytelling world that really
dives into the like one of the best
sci-fi films of all time plus all the
John wick tactical like gun yes it's
like it's the perfect game and it's so
cool to see him put in here it was born
to have a robot arm yeah I want to know
more about who is actually playing in
the game because this game looks great I
mean we love the gameplay trailer that
we saw from last year buy one like this
is like the biggest of nitpicks that
anyone could conjure up this is almost
as if I'm looking for something to
nitpick the faces look so photorealistic
it looks an incredibly realistic but
there are times where they're talking
where the expression doesn't fully look
there and the way how I'm like I feel
like your eyebrows or eyes or mouth
should be open removing a little more
there but hardest they still got a year
before it comes out to fine-tune that
other than that this whole game looks
great addition of Keanu who is just
having the most epic year John wick 3 is
the highest-grossing one in the
franchise and pretty much happened like
that in one week at Toy Story for the
first reactions have come out and it
seems like the primary praise is going
not just sort of storytelling but Keanu
Reeves in that movie obviously mind
maybe got he's not if you guys haven't
totally seen that scene that's going
around social media it's hysterical and
now he's stolen the show at e3 and also
this year Bill and Ted 3 was announced
everyone fish' lee and everyone got
jacked up so this is Kiana's year yeah I
had no idea he was I didn't hear any
reports about he's gonna be in styrofoam
or be involved in cyberpunk at all and I
like that he led with the angle of who
wasn't trying to BS anything it didn't
even sound I could really knew much
about video games how he led with the
angle of storytelling yeah because a
story for someone like me who picks up
games like throughout the month
but I take a long time to play games I'm
always choosing the storyline games yeah
so talking about like the world building
and him wanting to do it cuz of story
purposes all right well if kion is like
excited for that you know yeah that
makes me excited for this too yeah I
mean it's been a while since I've gotten
to game avidly but I think 2020 I'm
gonna set a goal like what by the time
this game comes out I'm gonna be ready
to jump it's cool there's no pressure
because it's not a franchise yeah the
first one so you can't just jump into
this and something like it's so cool
that there's something new out there
that it seems like a lot of people are
gonna be eager to jump in on together
you know because also it does have that
second life type thing where you can
make your own persona upgrade it and
really live it through the games I hope
this comes out in a VR for ya because to
be able to look around that I got
imagine will be insane I hope so too I'm
gonna want to go to sleep soon since I
haven't slept guys make sure to go check
out Dan and Elissa is a channel you send
them send them some love tell my
congratulations we're on social media or
something like that keep an eye out for
their twitch streamed wedding subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell hit the like button if
you like this video and we'll cover some
more of a three trailers keep a lookout
the ones that were mainly interested in